[Musique]
on retrouve pour le panel politique et
buzetti Michel coger et Christian Dufour
bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir madame
commençons avec l'ingérence chinoise
dans les élections fédérales bon ça fait
des jours qu'on en parle mais là les
appels à une enquête publique deviennent
de plus en plus insistance multiplient
jusqu'à un Trudeau résiste jusqu'à
maintenant à votre avis Hélène est-ce
qu'il faut une enquête publique
écoutez c'est pas moi qui va trancher
cette question mais c'est intéressant
qu'il y a plusieurs personnes qui
émanent de l'entourage soit de
l'entourage de Monsieur Trudeau ou des
personnes considérées comme neutre qui
en demandent une
ceci dit deux choses d'abord je suis
convaincu que ce n'est pas un comité
parlementaire qui réussira à aller au
fond des choses on sait que déjà un
comité qui se penche sur des allégations
similaires concernant la précédente
élection celle de 2019 et on le voit
déjà et comme on l'a vu dans tellement
d'autres occasions madeleines quand on
observe la sainte politique par fédérale
les comités sont souvent une occasion de
partisannerie on a des témoins on leur
pose pas nécessairement les bonnes
questions on les invite pas à creuser
leur idée quand il commence à ouvrir la
porte sur quelque chose d'intéressant
tout ce qui les intéresse c'est surtout
de marquer des points politiques il ne
cherche pas de temps à chercher à
trouver la vérité qu'à entendre une
vérité qui les conforterait dans leur
opinion donc je pense pas que c'est du
côté d'un comité parlementaire qu'on va
faire toute cette lumière
le problème d'une commission d'enquête
elle pourrait pas vraiment être publique
parce que on devrait avoir accès à
toutes sortes de documents classifiés
secrètes secrets et donc il faudrait
faire ça en grande partie derrière des
porte-closes donc il faudrait s'en
remettre finalement au jugement ultime
que porterait le président de cette
commission et dans un contexte où
Monsieur Trudeau mine
la confiance générale c'est ça qui
m'inquiète c'est qu'en ce moment avec
son attitude les gens finiront par ne
pas avoir confiance tant tu es aussi
longtemps qu'ils ne verront pas des
documents qui ne pourront pas voir de
toute manière Christian et Michel je
reviens à vous dans un instant mais
d'abord écoutons juste un Trudeau là qui
parle justement des mécanismes qui sont
déjà en place qui fait valoir que ce qui
est en place semble suffisant à ses yeux
et écoutons-le et on vient
c'est pourquoi au Canada on a créé deux
nouveaux mécanismes un groupe de travail
de nos agents de sécurité mais aussi un
panneau de haut fonctionnaire qui était
là pour évaluer l'intégrité de nos
élections pendant que ça se passait en
2019 et en 2021 c'est ces experts ont
conclu que l'intégrité de nos élections
n'ont pas été compromisées mais ils ont
souligné que on fait constamment face à
des attentats d'ingérence par des pays
étrangers comme la Chine et d'autres
Michel est-ce qu'il vous convainc est-ce
que les mécanismes en place sont
suffisants à votre avis ou l'idée d'une
enquête publique serait une idée à
explorer
il y a quelque chose à explorer dans
l'idée d'une enquête publique mais elle
a raison si c'est une enquête ou une
fois de temps en temps on dit ah ça
c'est on peut pas en parler ceci on peut
pas en parler ça va juste nuire à la
cause plutôt que de l'aider mais
l'influence de la Chine au Canada
dépasse largement les élections on sait
ce qui se passe il y a des postes de
police clandestins opéré par la Chine
dans les communautés chinoises il y a
les études dans les universités il y a
énormément d'influences chinoises
actuellement et toute cette influence là
et devient d'abord quelque chose qu'il
faut regarder et d'autre part les
Canadiens commencent à se dire est-ce
qu'on est bien protégé contre ça on a vu
ces voici un régime qui a pris deux
Canadiens en notaires pendant deux ans
un humain pas fiable et je trouve que le
Canada est plus vulnérable que les
autres démocraties libérales entre
autres parce qu'au Canada il sacralisé
un multiculturalisme sans aucune limite
en fait qui fait qu'un espèce
d'angélisme là-dedans comme le dit
Michel il y a des communautés en fait de
Canadiens d'origine étrangère qui sont
influencés par la chaîne qui sont
intimidés par la Chine il y a d'autres
questions qu'on se pose on n'a pas de
réponse formelle donc je sais pas si
c'est une comme ça dans laquelle ou pas
mais reste qu'il faudrait vraiment que
le gouvernement prenne ça au sérieux
parce que c'est juste le début de
quelque chose qui va s'accentuer qui est
totalement inacceptable mais je le
rappelle je sais que c'est quelque chose
que des jeunes pas qu'on dise le muscule
curalisme canadien le sang limite le
sacralisé là ça produit entre autres on
est plus vulnérable qu'ils ont
démocratie libérale parce que le message
qu'on a vu que les gens d'origine
étrangère bon puis garder des liens avec
vos pays d'origine puis le pays
d'origine comprend l'idée la Chine est
extrêmement efficace rappelant que ce
que la chaîne a essayé de faire c'est
très très habile c'est très précis là je
vais te donner rendu loin puis ça va ça
va empirer ce qu'on comme information se
sont surtout les médias là qui nous
l'ont révélé jusqu'à maintenant Hélène
et c'est aussi ça peut-être aussi la
question est-ce que il est possible
d'avoir de l'information sans que ce
soit nécessairement grâce et une chance
que les médias sont là mais grâce au
travail des médias
oui mais c'est sûr et ça soulève toute
la question de qu'est-ce qu'on ne nous
dit pas monsieur Trudeau aujourd'hui a
quand même eu une posture partisan assez
particulière il nous a répété
un mot à peine couvert que bon si les
conservateurs s'intéressant à cette
question aussi bien c'est un peu pour
imiter Donald Trump aux États-Unis et
jeter un doute sur la légitimité de la
dernière élection ça c'est quelque chose
qu'il avait dit et que surtout ça député
notre Jennifer au canon avait dit même à
l'automne dernier quand les autres
révélations le concernant l'élection
2019 était sortie mais aujourd'hui
monsieur Trudeau est allé plus loin et
ça va faire un lien avec ce que
Christian vient juste de dire il le dit
et c'est assez étrange disait là depuis
deux trois ans il y a une montée de
racisme anti-asiatique et il est
essentiellement sous-entendre que toutes
ces questions là sont peut-être un peu
xénophobes enfin c'est comme ça que je
l'ai compris parce que dans le fond on
cible une communauté en particulier
alors ça devient troublant parce que
Monsieur Trudeau comme se cache derrière
ce paravent de l'importance de la
diversité du multiculturalisme pour ne
pas répondre aux questions et il le dit
deuxième chose que j'ai trouvé assez
étonnante parce qu'on lui posait la
question avez-vous été informé comme le
soutien le réseau global le média global
avez-vous été informé que votre candidat
devenu député
avait des liens problématiques avec le
régime chinois il n'a jamais voulu
répondre et paraît-il que le service de
renseignement disait que ce candidat ne
devrait pas être candidat et Monsieur
Trudeau c'est insurgé en disant ce n'est
pas à nos agents de renseignements qui
ne sont pas élus de nous dire qui
devrait ou ne devrait pas être candidat
alors je ne sais pas si les agences de
renseignements devraient avoir le
dernier mot en ces matières mais quand
même est-ce qu'il est en train de nous
dire qu'il n'écoute pas les agences de
renseignements est-ce qu'il est en train
de nous dire qu'on ne doit pas poser des
questions à propos de la Chine parce que
c'est RAC il y a quand même des drôles
de parade de la part de Monsieur Trudeau
qui viennent un peu obscurcir justement
le tableau et donner moins confiance aux
gens plutôt que plus
Christian malheureusement je vais vous
faire intervenir sur un autre sujet donc
je vais essayer de couper court à
celui-là on était en pause par le
commentaire cette semaine à Ottawa mais
ça va sûrement venir la semaine
prochaine lorsque le Parlement va se
remettre à ce que j'ai l'autre sujet
dont je vais vous parler c'est de cette
lettre du chef du Parti québécois Paul
Saker qui a fait parvenir au premier
ministre du Québec hier demandant une
sorte de nouvelle Commission sur
l'avenir du Québec à l'image de la
commission Bélanger Campo donc je vous
le fait d'extrait de sa lettre il dit
devant de telles constat j'en appelle à
votre sens du devoir je vous demande à
nouveau d'égaler au minimum le niveau de
nationalisme de vos prédécesseurs dont
Monsieur Robert Bourassa malgré son
allégeance fédéraliste l'ancien premier
ministre du Québec n'a pas eu peur de
mettre sur pied la commission Bélanger
Campo et au bureau de François Legault
on a répondu à la lettre en disant les
Québécois ont mis de côté ce débat qui
nous a divisé pendant plus de 50 ans
Monsieur saint-pierre-flamondon devrait
écouter la population
Christian qu'est-ce que Paul
Saint-Pierre flamandon est en train de
faire avec cette lettre à votre avis
qu'est-ce qu'il essaie d'accomplir nous
sommes un peu de vieux souvenirs
je dois avouer que c'est quelqu'un que
j'ai pas beaucoup pris au sérieux au
début je trouverai trop gentillet je
l'avoue on a des préjugés parfois bon il
y a aussi son opération sur le serment
d'Angleterre qui était pas un sujet qui
me touchait beaucoup mais qui l'a quand
même réussi ça devient une crédibilité
et là il revient avec quelque chose qui
me semble quand même assez habile
évidemment il y a aucune chance que
François Legault accepte ça mais reste
qui confirme son rôle de souverainiste
devrait s'ouvre-lisse comparé à Québec
solidaire dans le souverainisme est
complètement bidon peut aussi des Guyon
c'est à dire que son rôle politique est
souverainiste ça l'amène à attirer
l'attention sulfate que le Québec dans
les relations avec le reste du Canada il
peut très gagnant ces temps-ci Satan
monsieur Lego mais je trouve que pour
répondre à votre question pour pas le
saint-pierre plat Mondon ça me semble
quand même assez habile parce qu'ils
n'ont jamais réussi à faire parler de
lui alors qu'il est en Europe je pense
mais il se pose en faire des François
des intérêts du Québec dans une optique
souverainiste qu'on avait pas parlé il y
a longtemps Michel Christian parler de
son opération réussie avec le serment au
roi est-ce que ce sujet là au 30
traction pour Paul Saint-Pierre
flamandon qu'en avait le serment why
est-ce que pas un risque à un moment
donné qui soit déconnecté des mettant
des sujets de portefeuille des Québécois
par exemple
écoutez la raison pour laquelle on en
parle aujourd'hui c'est que fait cette
lettre là donc opération réussie pour
lui ce qui vous laisse qu'on parle de
lui pendant qu'il est pas long alors ça
c'est la première des choses la deuxième
c'est qu'on n'est pas dans la situation
de mélanger Carpeaux de quelque chose
d'extrêmement important symbolique de de
l'identité québécoise qui était par
exemple la société du 5e qui avait été
rejetée par le reste du Canada si à
chaque fois que le premier ministre un
mauvais deux semaines des relations que
derrière il faut convoquer la Grande
Commission ça n'aurait pas de sens mais
monsieur Lebeau va quand même pas
s'autoflageller dire j'ai eu une
mauvaise semaine convoquant une
commission pour dire que j'ai eu une
mauvaise semaine
reste que ça fait parler de Monsieur
Saint-Pierre plat Mondon et il occupe
le débat public plus que son groupe de
trois députés l'aurait permis
normalement alors pour lui c'est de la
visibilité puis quand on est le
quatrième sur quatre on a besoin Hélène
en quelques secondes opération mais
aussi oui ou non
je pense que personne n'y croit vraiment
je suis assez d'accord avec Michel on
remet pas en question l'avenir du Canada
simplement parce qu'on a manqué quelques
milliards en santé mais je pense que le
calcul c'est que l'électorat pékistes
est beaucoup aller à la CAQ et on plante
une petite graine pour plus tard quand
ces électeurs-là se seront tannés de
monsieur Legault on espère qu'il se
souvienne du PQ elle a une visite c'est
Michel c'est où j'ai Christian de four
merci à vous trois au revoir au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI